the big day is finally here after a full
18 months of waiting a new definition of
racism just dropped you see for a long
time the anti-defamation league defined
racism as quote the belief that a
particular race is superior or inferior
to another that a person's social or
moral traits are predetermined by his or
her inborn biological characteristics
then about 18 months ago during the blm
riots the adl redefined racism as
exclusively a white thing quote the
marginalization and or oppression of
people of color based on a socially
constructed racial hierarchy that
privileges white people and that
definition had been going great for the
left it's very simple white people bad
black people good
no no complications here
but then
then whoopi goldberg had to go and screw
it all up when she claimed that the
holocaust was not about racism
now everyone with two brain cells to rub
together who knew anything about the
nazis mocked whoopi goldberg's claim the
problem was that according to the new
leftist definition of racism she was 100
correct if racism is only something that
white people can inflict on people of
color
then the holocaust could not have been
racist
there were no people of color involved
in that
in that entire event
so they've changed the definition again
now
in this post-whoopi world the adl
defines racism as occurring
when individuals or institutions
show more favorable evaluation or
treatment of an individual or group
based on race or ethnicity but do not
get too attached to this definition the
adl has made clear this is an interim
quote unquote definition and a new
definition is sure to drop just as soon
as it's politically convenient i'm
michael knowles is the michael knowles
show
[Music]
back to the show my favorite comment
yesterday from frank s who says
looks like jeffrey toobin is the only
guy at cnn who can keep his hands to
himself
that's true that's true a little uh
you know damning with faint praise in
that regard but uh you're you're right
that's true two tuban's looking
relatively
better after what's going on with zucker
and all the rest of these people
not not great it's kind of uh you know
you want to be able to tell the
difference between between uh
[ __ ] and shinola you know you want to be
able to tell the difference between
guilt and gold you you want to be able
to ascertain some value in this world
and when you want real actual gold i
would strongly recommend you check out
birch gold 40 years ago ronald reagan
saw massive inflation unlike anything
the country had ever seen before until
today in reagan's own words
inflation is as violent as a mugger as
frightening as an armed robber and as
deadly as a hitman well i can't tell
that was either ronald reagan or john
voigt i'm not sure which voice that was
right now your retirement accounts are
under attack thanks to the inflationary
policies of this administration if you
have not yet called birch gold the only
people that i trust to help you
diversify your 401ks and iras into gold
then you are missing the boat actually
you're treading water without a life
vest birch gold has your life vest let
them help you convert an ira or 401k
into a tax sheltered ira in gold with
thousands of satisfied customers and an
a plus rating with the better business
bureau you can trust birch gold to
protect your savings
right now text knowles k-n-o-w-l-e-s
to 98 98 98 to get a free info kit on
gold reagan knew the biggest threat to
your wealth protect yours now text
knowles k w l e s to 9 8 9 8 9 8 to get
your free info kit now
it's very complicated to keep up with
the definition of racism it is very very
funny that whoopi goldberg's ignorant
comment was
correct according to according to the
adl actually which is a
jewish anti-defamation organization they
realized oh yikes this is we're talking
about an explicitly jewish issue there's
an explicitly jewish organization uh but
really the adl doesn't speak for jews it
speaks for radical leftists and i guess
radical leftist jews in particular and
so they said oh yikes okay we got to
change this and they changed the
definition but they're going to change
it again it's interim every it's always
words words words just changing our
reality
as the left sees fit speaking of race
racial politics are actually helping
conservatives out right now in new york
four black new yorkers are suing new
york city over
an illegal voting law a law that they
believe violates the law
what's the law well democrats on the
51-member new york city council last
month approved a provision
that will allow more than 800 000
foreign nationals
to vote in city-wide elections
illegal aliens people here on green
cards visas work permits not u.s
citizens will be able to vote in
elections in new york as long as they've
resided in the city
for 30 days
you just have to be there for one month
consecutively and you can vote in
city-wide elections
this seems awful this seems un-american
but but now the issue has become about
race
four black new york city residents
phyllis coachman de roy murdoch
catherine james and anthony gillies have
filed a lawsuit
the lawsuit makes this claim
the new york city council was aware of
the discriminatory impact that the
foreign citizen voting bill would have
on the voting strength of black voters
these concerns were raised by council
members despite the discriminatory
impact and the knowledge that the new
york city council was without legal
authority to grant foreign citizens the
right to vote the council moved forward
and passed the bill
this is a really clever way to go after
this law
it's a clever way because race is not
the point
the fact that
black people are upset that now
overwhelmingly hispanic people are going
to get
non-american hispanic people are going
to get an outsized share of the vote
that's that's their issue with the
voting law but the problem with the
voting law is that we shouldn't have
foreign nationals influencing our
government in america we shouldn't have
foreigners influencing our elections or
participating in our elections for
goodness sakes that's the issue but
we're not allowed to talk about that
anymore in our current culture we're not
allowed to say that the nation is a good
thing we're not allowed to say that
america is a good thing we're not
allowed to say that borders are real
we're not allowed to say that
non-americans are different than
americans we're not allowed to say any
of that we're not allowed to say that
the american people have a right to stop
the the advance of global liberalism
we're not allowed to say any of that the
one thing we're still allowed to talk
about is racism
because that has been the instrument
that the left has used to transform our
culture
and so now you've got some conservatives
using the racism argument playing the
race card against the left and they're
saying hold on hold on hold on what are
elections elections aren't just the
people
of a given place
showing up and and voting and exercising
control over their government
elections are different
voting groups
wielding their proportionate influence
and specifically because we now all say
race is the most important thing in the
whole wide world it's different racial
groups
and when you flood the country with a
bunch of guatemalans and hondurans and
nicaraguans a bunch of hispanics that's
the new racial group that
has only really existed for the past
half century it was that was another
creation of the life this idea that all
people who speak spanish all around the
world they're all the same thing somehow
well when you get more hispanics
voting that means you're decreasing the
black share of the vote and that is very
very racist
the argument is a little bit
silly it's not that it's silly i mean
these sorts of arguments influence our
politics i guess i would say the
argument is beside the point
that's not really the issue with this
law but
nevertheless i say it's very clever i
like it whatever works we got to stop
these laws we don't want foreigners
voting in our elections if this is the
argument that is going to persuade the
liberals in new york and the liberal
judges in new york to get rid of this
ridiculous law fine by me
let's do it i cheer them on good job
phyllis deroy catherine and anthony keep
it up very clever you got to be wise as
a serpent innocent as a dove i
absolutely love it speaking of the law
though increasingly we're just throwing
the law out the window in this country
the rule of law is falling apart you
heard yesterday joe biden say that he's
going to pick a nominee who understands
that the constitution is always evolving
and the words don't really mean what
they say they mean they just keep
changing man you know
doesn't it you know what if this word
now means the opposite of that word and
we've heard these kinds of arguments
from the left for a long time now
you have leftists cheering on the
squishy republicans
who are doing their bidding by throwing
the law out the window nicole wallace on
msnbc just gave a huge round of applause
to liz cheney precisely for how lawless
she and the other squishes are behaving
he's now conditioned his base to not
believe in elections elections now do
not matter and and that's where liz
cheney seems to be drawing a line and
bringing out an equally large arsenal by
being by being the first person to say
he's going to get away with nothing not
potential violations of the presidential
records act not potential witness
tampering not potential efforts to
overthrow an election she's going for
the whole package of sins which no one's
ever done people said oh well he
obstructed justice but you know we got
this law in the books at doj that says
we can't indict let's just say f the
laws we're going to hold this buffoon
this dangerous buffoon accountable once
and for all can she succeed
ken i hope she can succeed i love that
liz cheney is completely disregarding
the law throwing it out the window
saying f the law
i hate trump and i'm gonna get him
i actually give nicole wallace a lot of
credit here for admitting that this is
what liz cheney is doing i never again
want to hear
from the squish conservatives or from
the left for that matter that liz cheney
and adam kinzinger
and all of the other
clown conservatives fake conservatives
who only exist to do the bidding of the
left they're the respectable ones
they have respect for the rule of law
bill crystal calls his never trumper
group the rule of law republicans
republicans for the rule of law no
nicole wallace is admitting it's
actually the opposite all these squishes
don't care at all about the rule of law
they're ignoring the law they're
throwing they're saying f the law i hate
trump and so i'm just going to get him
and why because they say trump
is is not accepting the results of the
election
oh yeah where do you think he learned
that guys
where do you where do you think that
trump
learned that you don't need to accept
the results of an election you think it
might have anything to do with oh i
don't know
the the woman that he beat who still
doesn't accept the results of the 2016
election you think that might have
anything to do with i don't know al gore
and and all of the other democrats
including terry mcauliffe just ran for
governor of virginia who still won't
accept the results of the 2000 election
those elections by the way conducted in
an almost perfectly ordinary way unlike
2020 where all the rules were changed in
some cases obviously illegally and
contrary to state constitutions
well no that's different michael because
trump's bad it's fine to throw out the
law
if if it means that we can get rid of
the orange man that's what the left is
saying
that that's fine you're making a naked
political argument this is bare-knuckle
interest politics fine but don't you
ever tell me again
that the liberals are the ones defending
the rule of law it's a joke they're
they're even admitting that they're the
ones not doing it
now
when you want to protect not just your
country and your community but your home
i would strongly recommend you check out
ring you know all about ring i've been
telling you about ring for years that
amazing video doorbell where you can see
and speak to whoever is outside the door
whether you are in the house
whether you're at the office whether
you're on the other side of the world
well did you know that ring has an
award-winning alarm
yes the incredible ring alarm is an
award-winning home security system with
available professional monitoring it's
super easy to install even i can do that
really gives you peace of mind when for
instance when i'm on the road i can feel
safe and secure when my wife and baby
are at home or when we're all on the
road and i know that that our home is
protected not just from bad guys but
from freeze from fire from flood
it's also incredible that a ring alarm
for
many many months will cost you what the
old kinds of security systems used to
cost you for just one month it's it's
really an incredible deal
get that award-winning ring alarm get it
right now go to ring.com slash knowles
kwles get a great deal on the ring alarm
home security kit today ring.com
knowles
speaking of not trusting the government
i just saw
the most
pathetic
magnificent
absurd transparent display
of
incompetent almost certainly corrupt
government
maybe i've ever seen
this came yesterday
not from some foreign government that
came from our government
came from the state department it turns
out there's at least one actual
journalist one actual reporter left in
washington
the state department is trying to
ratchet up tensions with russia
over this issue of ukraine
and they've been trying a number of
different strategies to do this and
yesterday the state department and state
department spokesman what's his name ned
price made this claim that russia is
going to launch a false flag attack
that will then give them
a pretext to invade ukraine and the
reporter in the room had a very simple
question
only one reporter he said what is your
evidence and the state department
couldn't answer
what we know matt is what we what i have
just said that they have engaged in this
activity
in this planning activity but let me let
me because obviously this is not this is
not the first time we've made uh
these reports public you'll remember
that just a few weeks ago sorry
made what report public
if you let me finish i will tell you
what report we made public uh we told
you a few weeks ago that we have
information indicating russia also has
already prepositioned a group of
operatives to conduct a false flag
operation in eastern ukraine so that
matt to your question is an action that
russia has already taken it's an action
that you say that they have taken but
you have shown no evidence to
to to confirm that and i'm going to get
to the next question here which is what
is the evidence that they i mean this is
like crisis actors really this is like
alex jones territory you're getting into
now
um
what evidence do you have to support the
idea that there is some propaganda film
in the in in the making hold on i've got
to pause it there it only gets better
the state department only clowns itself
further the reason i have to pause it
though is the reporter did make a
mistake he said that the state
department is getting into alex jones
territory that is not true alex jones is
much more trustworthy than the state
department
alex jones has a much better record of
predictions than the state department
including the gay frogs he was right
about the gay frogs okay
and it's not i am damning with faint
praise a little bit here because the
state department and our federal
bureaucracy and the liberal
establishment has such a terrible record
that the reporter is saying you're
asking me to just take this on faith
that you're telling me the truth but you
guys are incompetent and liars so why am
i supposed to believe you
matt this is derived uh from information
known to the us government intelligence
information that we have declassified i
think okay well where is it where is
this information it is intelligence
information that we have declassified
well where is it where is the
declassified information i just
delivered it
look no you made a series of allegations
would you would you like us to print out
the topper because you will see a
transcript of this briefing that you can
print out for yourself it's not evidence
ned that's you saying it that's not
evidence i'm sorry
what would you like matt
i i would like to see some proof
i'd like some proof no well i'm giving
it to you
okay let's try this again mr state
department spokesman
what is the evidence that that
russia is going to launch a false flag
and that's why we need to go send a
zillion troops to ukraine and start a
war with russia
what is the evidence that that's going
to happen
well i just gave it to you
no you made an allegation yeah that's
right that's the evidence
i said so take my word for it take my
word for it
take my word for it
the people who have lied about
and or screwed up every major foreign
policy issue
almost for my entire lifetime
the fall of the berlin wall was the last
thing that the and actually they didn't
get that right either reagan was right
about the fall of the berlin wall and
the state department and those people
all tried to screw it up so actually
never mind forget that they've
these people have screwed up every
major foreign policy issue almost
without exception
for as far back as i can even remember
with historical memory
the people who told us that sanam
hussein was making nukes the people who
told us that kabul was not going to
forget about we have to go back to
ancient history with saddam and the
nukes what about kabul what about the
afghanistan debacle from a year ago we
were told
less than a year ago
we were told
that kabul was not going to fall it was
strong the afghan national government
was great it fell within weeks
with days
but trust us we're right
tr believe us give me a break bro
sorry i'm not even denying that that
vladimir putin would stage a false flag
the guy's capable of doing just about
anything
he's a former kgb agent who runs russia
and wants to greatly expand russia's
territory and has already invaded
russia's neighbors so i'm not saying he
wouldn't do it sure of course he could
do it
but but i ain't just taking the state
department's word for it
or the the rest of the federal blob i
just
they've squandered their credibility
they don't have credibility anymore and
that's not my fault
it's not it's not unpatriotic it's not
conspiratorial it's not
irrational not to believe
these people after they've gotten
everything wrong and lied to us for
decades you want you want us to go
invade ukraine ned price you want us to
go start a war with russia okay fine
show me the proof of these things though
don't just tell me to take your word for
it
because
your word and a buck 50 used to get you
a cup of coffee now you need 350 to get
a cup of coffee because of joe biden's
inflation
speaking of a lack of credibility from
this administration
joe biden
failed on the economy
failed on foreign policy as we have seen
failed on the border
failed on kovid remember i'm going to
shut down kovit and then now there's no
federal solution to covet failed on issu
issue after issue after issue after
issue he is now underwater on every
single issue he's considered one of the
worst presidents in american history
so now
as the democrats
are poised to head into disaster
in the midterm elections
joe biden has thrown hail mary
he says that he is going to cure cancer
my message today is this
we can do this
i promise you we can do this
for all those we lost
for all those we miss
we can end cancer as we know it
i committed to this fight when i was
vice president
it's one of the reasons why quite
frankly i ran for president
let there be no doubt
now that i am present this is a
presidential white house priority
okay joe biden is gonna
he's going to cure cancer
he's launching this initiative he's
going to take a moonshot except they
already launched this initiative they
launched this initiative when barack
obama was president he put joe biden in
charge of it
which is probably why nothing happened
he launched it now six years ago
and the
what they said at the time was they were
going to launch this moonshot to cure
cancer quote to make a decades worth of
advances in cancer prevention diagnosis
and treatment in five years
now it was six years ago it didn't
happen the whole idea of the president
announcing that he's going to cure
cancer was taken out of a west wing
episode this is the problem with a bunch
of brain-dead millennials running your
white house is that the only thing that
they really know about statecraft is
what they watched on a sitcom right i
suppose a network drama when they were
children written by aaron sorkin and
they think that's real life and they
think that's politics and so so this is
the best they've got
joe biden could not cure a mild cough
joe biden said i'm going to shut down
the virus i'm going to shut down kovid
and then he just admitted what less than
a month ago sorry there's no federal
solution you're on your own it's going
to be solved at the states we can't do
it
you can't cure the cough you are not
going to cure cancer he doesn't think
he's going to cure cancer none of these
people even the aaron sorkin fans who
are writing all of joe biden's speeches
don't think he's going to cure cancer
this is a distraction this is a hail
mary this is just a way of saying hey
don't look at the economy don't look at
foreign policy don't look at kovid
actually the other medical issue we're
trying to solve don't look at this don't
look at that
hey we're gonna you know if you re-elect
me everyone's gonna
have lots of money
and
health
and and it's gonna be big rock candy
mountain with the birds and the bees and
the cigarette trees no it's not
it's not gonna happen
none of that is going to happen what you
are watching is a flailing presidency
the best shot they have right now to to
stop the bleeding in the midterms is
ram their supreme court justice through
that seems like they actually will get
that and then make a bunch of pie in the
sky promises that get people not even
that people will believe but just
distract them from all of the carnage
and misery that everyone is seeing
around them
one of the
new flailing initiatives from joe biden
is more gun control
and and even this he's screwing up this
is usually a reliable
base democrat issue
doesn't appeal to the majority of
americans but it does appeal to the
democrat base and they're just trying to
keep them
happy enough
but but even that biden screwed up biden
made the claim during a press conference
on guns
that a glock
is a weapon of war
you know uh
the future's cut short by a man with a
stolen glock
with 40 rounds a magazine with 40 rounds
and
it's really a weapon of war
it's really a weapon of war
now
to be fair to joe biden he's not just
saying that the glock itself one of the
most common handguns if not the most
common handgun in america he's not just
saying that's a weapon of war
if a glock is a weapon of war then every
gun is a weapon of war
he's saying that the glock with the
magazine that holds a lot of rounds
that's what makes it a weapon of war
but
but then that just means that every gun
is a weapon of war because every gun
potentially
almost every gun potentially could have
a big magazine in it
right you just just swap out the
magazine
so so what biden is claiming is that
weapons of war are bad
we need to ban weapons of war
and every single gun can be a weapon of
war
does not take socrates to put that
together and say oh he wants to ban
all of the guns
i don't think that's going to play very
well either i do think that gun control
can work for democrats sometimes but not
not not this way this is but again it's
just appealing to the base because he's
already lost the middle he's already
lost
the
relative centrists
so now he's he's he is losing his base
right now he's just he's got to try to
get the base back first then he can try
to rebuild the coalition he just doesn't
seem to have enough time so now you say
oh yeah we're going to ban all the guns
he's basically become beto hell yeah oh
yeah we're going to ban your glocks
hey come on man
speaking of redefining words david
crosby
you do you remember david crosby
possibly david crosby was part of crosby
stills nash and young he's an old hippie
singer i actually like neil young
like joni mitchell
i like their music i like some of their
music not all of it but i like the
handful of songs that people know
you know our house it's sentimental but
it's okay teach your children that's
fine four and twenty there's some good
songs david crosby is now calling on
spotify to remove his music as well
not just neil young but crosby stills
and nash as well he wants to do it
because he wants to censor joe rogan but
he doesn't want to admit that he wants
to censor joe rogan here's what david
crosby said
uh yesterday he was responding to
someone who said some good advice
actually listen to joe rogan's show
before you demand his cancellation and
david responded and said i have not and
will not demand anything from spotify or
joe rogan i just don't want my music on
there if he's on there so i'm taking
mine off that is not censorship
no it's not censorship because it's not
working but it's obviously an attempt at
censorship give come on david david you
know i think david used to follow me on
twitter for a while so i always wondered
if his politics were really very far
left or maybe if it were a little more
complicated than that i don't think he
follows me anymore
but i wondered i said maybe he's a
little more moderate or maybe he just
doesn't think about politics all that
much because he's a musician and he's
focused on other things
regardless i'm going to assume the best
motives here
david is not being honest with himself
about this issue
a lot of people are not being honest
with themselves about the censorship
issue
what he is saying is
my music has value
and so i'm going to take it off of
spotify unless david crosby really
believes his music has absolutely no
value and his music whether it's on or
off spotify will not affect people's
behavior whatsoever
but i don't think anyone really believes
that
he's saying my music has value
and so here's an ultimatum it's rogan or
me
cancel rogan
and you get to keep sensor rogan and you
get to keep me
or don't censor rogan and i'm going to
take my ball and go home and i'm going
to add more pressure to you to censor
rogue and you're trying of course you're
trying to censor rogan
and by the way i don't think censorship
is bad in and of itself
i know that on the right now it's it's
become fashionable in the last five or
ten years
to take the position that censorship is
always bad that's not a conservative
position that's not an american position
that's not a coherent position we censor
all sorts of things very rightly so
we sensor snuff films we should sensors
we censor child pornography that's a
good thing we sense our obscenity more
broadly we censor certain words you're
not allowed to say certain ugly profane
words in polite company we always do
that we sense written schools in homes
in businesses in the public square we
always censor stuff every society
censors stuff
it was the libs in the 1960s who
pretended that censorship is bad in and
of itself and it was the conservatives
who said what the hell are you talking
about every society in history censors
certain things you don't want to censor
everything you don't want to have an
overbearing authoritarian kind of
censorship regime but yeah we're going
to have standards we're going to have
taboos and they said no you got to get
rid of all that so then we got rid of
all that and then what happens two
seconds later the minute they destroy
our standards they erect their own
standards and start censoring us
they never meant it it was always just a
it was always just an operation it was
always just a tool for them to come in
and reshape the culture
david you want to censor joe rogan who
i'm sure you've never listened to fine
fine okay
you know what you think joe rogan
violates the standards of the society
you want to live in okay i mean that's
insane but sure we're fine
but don't please do not relieve yourself
on my leg and tell me that it's raining
if you want censorship as everyone does
to some degree then own it admit it and
tell us what you want to censor
speaking of limits
and education
glenn younkin absolutely crushing it the
new governor of virginia
killing it along with the attorney
general who's doing a great job and the
superintendent of public instruction
also doing a great job
they have
now asked a court to let them become
plaintiffs
along with loss with with parents rather
who are suing loudoun county public
schools so now the governor the attorney
general and the head of education are
all going to sue
the loudoun county public schools along
with the parents they're going to join
the parents to sue the schools
to
get the schools to stop forcing the kids
to wear those stupid masks
junkin issued an executive order saying
that parents had the right to choose
whether their children must wear masks
at school or not
the liberal schools have refused not to
have refused to follow it they claim
that they don't need to follow executive
orders now glenn yonkin is wielding the
power of the state to remove the free
choice of the school districts and i
think that's awesome some squishes are
going to say no this is bad we need to
let the schools do whatever the schools
want it's not this is an overreach on
the part of the state i disagree we are
living in a time now where the left is
wielding a ton of political power and
the right because of
silly notions of of
government and very silly ideologies
have completely surrendered political
power that's bad we need to follow the
conan the barbarian strategy here when
we're talking about politics conan what
is best in political life
wrong
conan
what is best in life
to crush your enemies see them driven
before you and they hear the lamentation
of the women
that is good here here i wish i could
vote for that guy for governor not
schwarzenegger but conan the barbarian
the what i i want to have a caveat here
the really the best thing that we want
is a civilized orderly reasonable
government that is conducive toward the
good it shuts out it suppresses the bad
and it leads to human flourishing that's
what we want we want to be very very
reasonable
that doesn't mean that there are no
limits here whatsoever and when your
political opponents are being completely
unreasonable and wielding power
unreasonably you need to wield power too
justly morally absolutely but you gotta
wield it
and you want to hear the lamentations of
your political opponents you know next
thursday february 10th
will be the world premiere of shut-in
daily wire's first original film it's at
9 00 pm eastern 8 pm central over at
daily wire and over at the daily wire
youtube channel the suspenseful thriller
follows a young mother trapped in a
pantry by her violent ex and meth addict
friend and she must escape to save her
children before it's too late the daily
wire god king jeremy boring had this to
say
shut-in is a fiercely independent
powerful movie about motherhood and
redemption it's riveting it's
challenging it's highly entertaining
we cannot wait to release it next week
check out the trailer
sorry
[Music]
is
[Music]
jessica
i can smell the weakness from here
let me out please
what good is this doing now
i'm scared
now
you
must pay
your daughter
she's very pretty
[Music]
[Music]
it's premiering next thursday february
10th 9 pm eastern 8 pm central over the
daily wire youtube we enter the
entertainment space in order to send
hollywood a message you no longer have a
monopoly on the film industry the
release of shut-in is just the next step
improving it also if basketball is your
favorite sport but you're tired of
wokeness infiltrating the nba you're not
alone orlando magic player jonathan
isaac is publishing a book with the
daily wire about the rise of his career
his journey into faith and his strength
to stand alone in the face of immense
social pressure this autobiographical
account is going to be absolutely
fabulous the book is available for
pre-order at amazon get your copy today
also valentine's day is around the
corner get the official daily wire
valentines give it to your sweetheart
you can get one with my smiling face on
it saying that you leave me speechless
we'll be right back with the mailbag
welcome back to my favorite time of the
week when i get to hear from you in the
mailbag
first question up from
elijah esteemed puzzle master
i need some comment on the tragic news
this week that the new york times has
acquired wordle
i
i fear our days of posting our gray
yellow and green squares on social media
are numbered sincerely a fellow wordle
addict
here here is my thought elijah
nature's first green is gold her hardest
hue to hold
her early leaves a flower but only so an
hour
then leaf subsides to leaf
so eden sank to grief
so dawn goes down to day
nothing gold
can stay
next question from landry hey michael i
wanted to know your take on this is
there anything worse than death on one
hand i think yes
you can have torture which can
physically hurt more than death
but should we only take the physical
part into account sincerely just a guy
who wants to see peace between knowles
and shapiro
yeah there are things worse than death
death is very bad i don't want to say
that death is not bad
it's a punishment for original sin
right
it's the consequence of original sin
um
you know in a way you might say it's
sort of a blessing in a world that's
fallen
but
but everyone's gonna die
there are things that are worse than
death
uh you say that
torture seems like it would be worse
than death because it has more physical
pain but but i don't think that physical
pain is the worst thing in the world i
don't think that physical pain is worse
than death i think the thing that is
worse than death is
eternal damnation
i think i know this is a sort of a crazy
obscure point of view these days in our
modern secular materialist world
but i think that human beings have souls
and i think that we
are part physical but also part
spiritual and i think that our
spirit has an eternal destination and
furthermore i believe in the
resurrection i believe in the
resurrection of the body and the life of
the world to come and i think that there
is justice in the world and i think that
there is a moral order and we will be
held to account for the things that we
have done
for what we've done in our thoughts and
in our words and what we've done and
what we've failed to do through our most
grievous fault and i think that there is
an off-ramp i think there's an off-ramp
to salvation offered by jesus christ our
lord and savior
and i'm i'm laughing about it because
this is so basic and this is the sort of
thing that created western civilization
and now if you say it to people they
look at you like you've got three heads
they look at you like you're completely
crazy
if you look if you look at people today
and you say hey
uh all of our hopes and joys and dreams
and our intuitions of the moral world
and the idea that there's justice and
our natural human longing
and not longing for and knowledge of god
who can be known with certainty by the
light of of reason from the natural
world
i don't think that's just an illusion i
don't think that's i don't think it's
all just fake because some synapses are
firing off in our brain i don't think
that we're really just worm food i don't
think that
petting a little puppy on a nice summer
day is the same thing as killing a bunch
of babies i don't think it's all just
like stuff and flesh
i don't here's a good example i don't
think that consensual sex between a
married couple
and rape
is the same thing
physically it looks basically like the
same thing the physical action is the
same but i don't think they're the same
thing because i think there is a
spiritual world because i think there's
more
there's more to life that matters than
just matter so yes there are things that
are worse than death though you will die
so get ready for it make sure make sure
you're ready to die life is a
preparation for death in many ways
on that note no i'm kidding there's more
from jessica hey michael i recently have
re-entered the dating world uh i will
pause for the flood of comments in the
subscriber section to settle down as
they all want to chance with me fair
enough
anyway i was wondering uh what your
thoughts are on dating multiple people
at once
when you first start going on dates and
start to like someone should you force
yourself to date other people
simultaneously even if you like one
person i hear advice about dating
multiple people at once to not only keep
your options open but to make sure you
don't seem desperate or needy should i
force myself to keep
finding and talking to other guys when
dating and until it's exclusive
sincerely do i need a deep bench this is
a really good question
because
the short answer is no but the longer
answer is maybe by which i mean
no it's you don't need to
go and spend all your time you know
flirting with all these other guys that
you're not really interested in
just because of this terrible fear that
the guy that you are interested in might
not like you quite as much and so you'll
you'll you might be left alone for a
couple of weeks and that's unacceptable
so you've got to be playing the field
and
whether that means going out to dinner
or whether that means something a little
more invasive you know that that would
uh no i don't think you need to do that
however
your point here about not seeming too
needy
or wanting
the guy maybe to know that you're dating
other people so that he
likes you more or is feels greater
urgency to seal the deal
that's a very legitimate intuition
the way that desire works i mentioned
this name on the show months ago renee
gerard he was this sociologist who has
this idea of desire as being memetic
meaning we imitate others desires the
reason that you want the leftist tears
tumbler is not merely because it is a
beautiful vessel filled to the brim with
delicious salty leftist tears
at a deeper level the reason you want
the leftist tears tumbler is because
other people want the leftist tears
tumbler
you see that other people want it and
you imitate that desire we don't just
imitate people in terms of their
behavior
which we we all do we're human beings
are imitative creatures
right we i i see dr fauci and i see him
give some stupid speech and then i
imitate him i say well now listen here
you dirty peasant we're doing that
because human beings naturally imitate
one another and how do we learn how to
behave well we imitate our parents we
imitate our teachers we imitate our
friends this is why people say you were
known by the friends you keep because
the people you spend the most time with
you're just naturally going to imitate
them because that's how human being
human beings are
well the same is true not just for our
behavior but for our desires you
actually
desire the things that the people that
you admire and the people you spend time
with desire
they shape not only the way you act but
your desires as well
and so
you see this in love affairs because
and i i
i promise you every guy at least every
guy and probably every woman out there i
i actually think this is true regardless
of sex
if you're interested in someone
you think okay i like that girl's pretty
cute and i like that girl she's kind of
cute too and whatever maybe i'll you
know maybe i'll try it out and date a
few people and then you notice that a
bunch of other guys are trying to date
that first girl you are going to
desire that first girl even more same
thing with the guys you'll notice this i
noticed this in my single life
there were times if i was
you know lucky with the ladies if i were
if
i was a period of time where lots of
gals were interested in me
more and more gals would be interested
in me
but if it was a period of time where
where i was not dating people then many
fewer people were interested in me and
this is true for i'm sure you have
experienced this in your own life i'm
you know this is kind of what happens in
the petri dish of colleges or in you
know cities
why is that why do these things come in
waves because we imitate one another's
desires so as a tactical matter
this is why women send flowers to
themselves
right to make to trick other guys and
make them think that others are
interested in them so you know as a
tactical matter maybe but you know
preserve your modesty darling don't
preserve your virtue from nicole dear mr
knowles i am a big fan of your podcast
and your book speechless thank you
however
something you said on all access live
really startled me you said that women
can reform men am i to believe that you
think a woman can can or should date a
man with the intention of changing him
this is something i don't think is
possible or healthy sincerely came for
ben stayed for knowles subscribe for
clavin fair enough fair enough
uh
i don't just think it can happen i think
it inevitably happens
and actually i guess my previous answer
is this was a great transition into this
answer
we
naturally shape the people that we are
with that's just how human nature works
so
i'm not saying you know if you're if
you're gonna get married to some
degenerate abusive guy i'm not saying
you can i can change him and you'll
totally reform him but he but he will
change you
people grow together or they grow apart
they do shape one another
and so yeah that will happen
when men are bachelors they live like
bachelors almost without exception
they don't do their laundry as much as
they should they don't cook as much as
they should they don't clean as much as
they should they don't sleep as well as
they should they go out too much they
that's just what they do maybe they play
too many video games and then you get
married and you stop that stuff or you
greatly reduce it or you change the way
you behave that's inevitable
and
that's one of the reasons that people
get married is to move on with their
lives and to grow and to develop from
maddie hey michael recently someone told
me that they think romance novels movies
etc are as bad to women as porn is to
men while these two are not on the same
level for obvious reasons it did make me
think about the tick-tock trend talking
about the appeal of men written by women
do you think growing up watching movies
like pride and prejudice and the titanic
gives women unrealistic hopes
that is do i need to leave the romance
to fiction and just settle down with
someone practical
no i don't think so i i think
we live in a culture right now where men
have been particularly degraded by the
educational system by the culture by the
licentiousness throughout the society
that's now tolerated by the government
and and by women who are willing to uh
give them the milk for free and so they
have no
particular incentive uh at least at the
material level to uh to go by the cow so
i don't think it's wrong for women to
aim for something higher than just some
loaf couch potato idiot man who has no
ambition and just eats potato chips all
day
i think you can aim higher but but the
one thing i would recommend is
maybe you want your mr darcy to use your
pride and prejudice reference you want a
man like mr darcy
but
don't make an idol out of mr darcy i'm
actually going to take it out of the
realm of romance for a second and put it
into the realm of your career this might
be a little easier to understand people
have
heroes
people
when they think about their life and
their career they say i want to be like
ronald reagan
i want to be like uh i don't know elon
musk i want to be like donald trump i
want to be
and that's good it's good to have those
goals in mind and to say okay he did
this so maybe i should do something like
this or this that or the other thing
but you can't just replicate someone
else's career you're not just gonna be
ronald reagan and do all the things
ronald reagan did or you're not just
gonna do all the things elon musk did
you're not just going to you're not
going to get exactly mr darcy
okay it's good to have the these virtues
in mind and these good habits in mind
and these good attributes in mind
but
when you make an idol out of them then
you really are living in a fantasy and
then you really will be disappointed
from ava michael i'm 14 years old no for
wow this is i love that we are just
completely corrupting the youth away
from the extremely corrupt
modern culture and toward something a
little more conservative that's great
thank you ava uh
14 years old no friends sorry to hear
that homeschooled for two years now no
reliable means of travel very untrusting
parents
i converted to catholicism after hearing
you talk more and more about it
and because of you i was turned to god
and i am now a better educated and
pretty established catholic wow great
news that's so wonderful to hear that's
terrific
my issue is that my family does not
approve my mom has made fun of the faith
bribed me to leave the catholic faith
behind and has not taken me to another
church since she mocked my first mass
that's unfortunate
it's made me very nervous about my
standing with god knowing that i have no
way to go to confession or even do an
rcia program so i can get baptized the
only way i'm able to practice at the
moment is my rosary which i was able to
buy online i have since
never wanted to say a word about my
religion to my family because they
reject it makes it hard
for me worrying about the states of
their souls as well um what should i do
i keep pushing to go to a church
preferably a latin mass or just wait
until i turn 16 i can drive myself
please help a long question but yeah a
really tough predicament that you are in
the one thing i would say if you're
really worried about the state of your
soul
is to remember
that
you have limitations put on you right
now and that's just the way of the world
i'll give you an example of a
little-known fella goes by the name of
saint thomas aquinas maybe you heard of
him
thomas aquinas wanted to join the
uh dominican order i think his parents
wanted him to join the embassy but he
wanted to become a dominican parents
were really upset about this they
kidnapped him they locked him in a tower
they sent loose women to try to
the at least according to legend to try
to uh loosen him up you know and uh they
they tried to persuade him not to to go
join the ambassador not to become a
dominican he held firm when he was
finally able to break out he did that
there is also you haven't been baptized
you say there is there is such a thing
according to saint thomas aquinas and
the tradition of holy mother church of
uh baptism of desire
this is not to say that you shouldn't
get baptized the first chance you can to
have a real baptism in you know in real
life with your real physical body but
there is such a thing as baptism of
desire this was true for the catechumens
people who wanted to get into the church
but had not yet been baptized if they
were martyred for instance uh the
tradition of the church says
yes absolutely there is such a baptism
uh that takes place even before the
physical actual sacramental baptism so i
think you're okay
in that regard i would uh you know right
now
pray the rosary
you can stream
masses if you like it's not ideal but
you can do it you can read a lot watch
videos grow in your faith
pray
pray for your family he'll try to work
this thing out sometimes they get a
little shocked when people convert
and uh and then look forward with hope
which is a theological virtue toward the
future we can do that certainly in our
spiritual life and i think everyone can
do that in our political life as well
i'm michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show see you monday
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadofsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022 hey
everybody this is andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin